jan prämierte papst benedikt soll
zeitungsberichten zufolge schwer
erkrankt sein
nach seiner reise nach deutschland nach
regensburg wo er sein inzwischen
verstorbenen bruder georg besuchte
venedig leidet seit seiner rückkehr nach
rom an einer gesichtslose berichtet die
passauer neue presse unter berufung auf
den autor peter seewald dieser habe
benedikt dem sechzehnten am samstag
seine biografie über den emiraten papst
überreicht dann über diese krankheit
möchte ich jetzt noch genauer sprechen
mit dr
yael adler sie ist mir nun live
zugeschaltet guten morgen frau dr
sagen sie mir was genau ist eine
gesichtslose und wie entwickelt sich
diese überhaupt jeder kennt ja
wahrscheinlich die diagnose gürtelrose
das ist eine reaktivierung der
windpocken also wenn wir als kinder
windpocken hatten ziehen sich diese
viren waren installation ihren zurück in
schaltstellen in der tiefe unseres
körpers wo und nerven verschaltet werden
und wenn dann das immunsystem mal nicht
so kräftig ist dann können die an den
nerven entlang hervor kriechen bis zur
haut die machen dann schmerzen werfen
dann blasen und es dauert ungefähr eine
woche bis die blase nachteilen aber
vorher hat man oft schon über schmerzen
und danach manchmal auch wenn sich das
ganze im gesicht abspielt dann nennt man
das eben gesichtslose und nicht
gürtelrose aber im grunde ist es
dasselbe
und hier ist eben die gefahr dass
weitere gesichtsnerven gehirn nerven
gefallen werden die dann in
mitleidenschaft gezogen werden und
deswegen ist das eine diagnose die man
am liebsten nicht zu hause aus setzt
sondern im krankenhaus behandelt dass
man darauf aufpasst dass der mensch
keine spätfolgen entwickelt ist diese
krankheit denn lebensbedrohlich vor
allem im hohen alter bis jetzt bei papst
benedikt dem sechzehnten der fall ist
also jede - erkrankungen kann den körper
sehr schwächen meistens aber trägt man
das gut behandelt es gibt gute
medikamente wenn man rechtzeitig anfängt
also auch im hohen lebensalter kann das
durchaus sehr gut ausgehen
das gehört bei jungen menschen sogar auf
manchmal dazu wenn die wirklich
die krankheit haben und bei alten
menschen einfach auch mal so da ist das
immunsystem nicht mehr ganz so flink
wichtig ist dass man rechtzeitig anfängt
mit den medikamenten dass man schauen
dass die schmerzen gut behandelt sind
dass sie auch im nachhinein ich bleiben
dass man dann auch antientzündlich
behandelt dass da nicht irgendwelche
schwellungen sind im kopf ist ja alles
ein bisschen enger und dass man die
hautveränderungen antientzündlich
behandelt also von innen und von außen
und dann den menschen unterstützt sein
immunsystem stärkt mit b vitaminen
vitamin d zingg und solche dinge und
dann kann das alles sehr gut ausgehen